tonight we embark on an epic five-week
tournament our battle of the branches
competition top bladesmiths from four
branches of our united states armed
forces army air force marine corps and
navy will put their blade making skills
to the test the winner from each branch
will go head to head for our biggest
cash prize ever fifty thousand dollars
right now round one belongs to the army
furman tyler congratulations you boys
have made it into the final round of
this competition which means that you're
both one step closer to representing the
army in our battle of the branches final
now we're sending you back to your home
for just to recreate this iconic weapon
the u.s army officer sword
oh
the sabrin
the u.s army officer saber has adorned
the dress uniforms of the top brass for
over a century but its predecessors are
as old as america itself
since the establishment of the first
continental army by the second
continental congress in june of 1775
american officers have been carrying
their swords into battle as firearms
slowly replaced swords in combat the
ceremonial officer saber was unveiled in
1902 though shorter and more delicately
curved this highly decorated weapon
descends from the fierce battle swords
of the u.s cavalry today the army
officer saber remains a crowd pleaser at
military ceremonies weddings and parades
all right soldiers your weapons look
beautiful but were they born to kill to
find that out i'm going to take your
weapons and deliver slashes and thrust
on this ballistics dummy tyler you're up
first you ready for this ready as i'll
ever be
you need those teeth
at last poor uric i knew him well
all right tyler this edge is sharp i
mean just pulling out of that look how
deeply it cut this ballistics dummy now
in cutting the spine and the jaw
it took a little bit of glinting but no
major chips stayed straight
and most of all
it will kill thank you
put them in are you ready sir yes sir
[Music]
as soon as i see the band on my blade my
heart stops
all right tremendous your edge will
lacerate and cut flesh
your tip is sharp to puncture from the
back even into the heart and it
lacerates on the way out
but in cutting the head and cutting that
spine it did take a bend and there's
light chipping on the edge of your blade
but your weapon sir will kill
yeah
bladesmiths
welcome to the strength test
to test the strength of your blade and
the overall construction of your sabers
i'm going to beat them violently into
these helmets like they were being worn
by my mortal enemy now i'm not really
concerned about what your saber does to
the helmets of the dummy i want to see
what the helmet and dummy are going to
do to your sabers now furman we're going
to let your blood pressure cool down a
little bit thank you tyler you're going
to go first you ready
yep
furman's blade takes a bend and mine
could be next could go anywhere i don't
know what's gonna happen
[Music]
tyler's a beast
you got some chipping on the edge i can
catch my nail on
i don't see any
pulls or delaminations in your steel
still in one piece it's still sharp good
job thank you
furman how you feeling
well we're gonna do it anyway
[Laughter]
my palms are sweating i'm almost
hyperventilating i'm shaking
all right friend we got two problems one
your blade is just continuing to bend
pretty soon it's going to be a 90 degree
angle
the other thing is your handle grooves
are shoving my hand
right up against the guard and it's just
bashing my knuckles up into it you can
see
my back two knuckles already starting to
turn blue and swell that's a really big
problem for me
[Music]
gentlemen these tests are intentionally
brutal and severe to set your blades
apart from one another furman we had a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test and we just cannot
continue testing with that bent blade
i have to dismiss you from the forge
thank you so much
thank you
tyler congratulations you've earned the
army's and villain our battle of the
branch's final competition where you'll
have a chance to win the title of forged
and fire champion for the army and
a check for 50 000
good job
brother it feels amazing but this is
just the first step i still got to go up
against the navy the marines and the air
force to prove that the army can take it
all i'm tyler hackbaugh i'm the army
champion and i'm coming for you guys
the united states air force
non-commissioned officer sword
despite having no historical use of
swords the u.s air force utilizes
ceremonial weapons like the
non-commissioned officer sword as a nod
to their roots in the army
based on the european pillow sword the
nco is a lightning-fast stabbing weapon
that can be unleashed with lethal
precision enable hands small-looped
quillians form the nco's cross guard and
its flattened blade extends to a point
about 28 inches away
the nco sword's sleek design is the
ideal symbol for the air force's
stealthy enemy vanquishing power all
right airmen now we'll take your weapon
and deliver some thrust and slashes on
this ballistics dummy
mike you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do it
[Music]
all right mike
it's a very light sword because of that
you can move with it now your tip allows
for a nice thrust with your edge it
slices i can feel every cut in there but
more importantly
it will kill
thank you all right matt your turn you
ready sir yes sir
nice
all right matt's talking about your
blade here
the edge that you have here is very
sharp the point punctures nicely and
most importantly sir
it'll kill awesome thank you
all right next up the strength test for
that we have ben
hello bladesmiths to test the strength
and durability of your swords as well as
their overall construction i'll be
bashing them into this propeller
mike you're up first you ready
no
we're gonna do it anyway all right
good job
well mike
your blade held up great the only issue
i have with it is that i would really
like this pommel to be bigger if the
pommel were bigger it would give me a
stop but it's got a nice weight
it's still sharp as when it started
really well done thank you so much
matt you're up what are you thinking
ready all right
[Music]
[Music]
bad ass
well matt your blade
held up great
it's still sharp
this is a much heavier sword but the
biggest issue i have is with the cross
card and back your cross guard is loose
it wiggles and also your wire wrap is
loose
but
it's all in one piece it did a heck of a
thing on that propeller well done thank
you when we're not finished yet next up
is the sharpness test and for that i
give you the dug
all right airmen to test the edge of
your blade i'm going to be cutting
across these harnesses
i'm looking for clean cuts
mike you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
do this
[Music]
good job thank you okay
sharp all right mike
light and flight and sharp enough to cut
through the harness it would cut thanks
sir good job thanks man all right matt
your turn sir you ready yes sir let's do
this i need my blade to cut right
through these straps like butter
all right matt let's talk about your
blade here it's kind of heavy
it's so forward in its weight that on
this slash using the last six inches it
just scratched the back of the harness
but on the backhand swing where it's
going all the way through it cut the
harness
but your weapon sir it will cut thanks
good job man thanks coming into this
matt and i promised each other that our
goal was to make each other earn it he's
a heck of a smith so it's in the judge's
hands now
mike matt the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision about which of you will move
forward to our battle of the branch's
final competition to represent the air
force at the air force's anvil the
bladesmith moving forward is
mike congratulations
thank you
matt at this time i have to ask you to
please surrender your blade
i feel good no matter what i mean i'm
glad i made it here good job thank you
i'm proud of myself for sure
mike they said you're only as good as
your competition and you overcame a
fantastic competitor to move forward in
this competition to represent the entire
branch of the air force at our battle of
the branches competition how do you feel
feels amazing
please present your blade to the judges
i can't believe i'm the air force
champion i'm looking forward to showing
the rest of the dod what we've got
there's a lot of added pressure moving
forward now i'm competing against the
army the navy and the marine corps and
we've got a little bit of a rivalry
going on so you better bring it because
you know i'm going to
your final challenge is to forge a
marine corps officer's sword also known
as a mammal luke
since 1825 the mama luke sword has been
awarded to u.s marines to recognize
extraordinary service
this tradition began when the rulers of
tripoli bestowed this weapon upon marine
lieutenant presley o'bannon for his
bravery during the battle of derna
the weapon itself originates from the
ottoman empire in persia with many
similarities to the persian sham sheer
featuring a thin blade shallow curve and
its signature inward curved pommel this
deadly sword was ideal for cavalry and
foot soldiers to deliver lethal slashes
and thrusts on their enemy
this blade was so dangerous legend had
it that it was nearly unbreakable and
could cut a person in two
all right marines welcome to the kill
test
to find out what lethal damage your
weapon will do i'll take your weapon
never killing blows to this ballistics
dummy trippy up first you ready for this
get it killer hoorah
going into this kill test man i just
hope that it performs better than the k
bar that i made
yikes
oh
holy moly
all right trip first up the handle
construction
it is comfortable
your edge here is sharp even cutting
through the skull no issues at all no
chipping no blinding and when you thrust
with this it penetrates and cuts all the
way out overall sir your weapon
will kill all right here raw
all right gene you're next you ready
let's do this
[Music]
oh no it bent it
all right gene
your weapon picked up a warp right here
okay your handle coupled with blood all
over made it very slippery and hard to
hold on to because it's blocky and
smooth and i lost my grip on it that's a
very dangerous thing to happen when
you're trying to wield the weapon but
your edge is still sharp your tip is
still thrustable and more importantly
it will kill
that'll work
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test so to test the overall
construction of your blade and see if
they're going to hold an edge i'll be
smashing into these pots
now remember this test is not about what
your swords do to those pots but those
pots do your swords trip you up you
ready ready okay
yup holy moly
dog
well tripp
a few things before we get to the
obvious your handle construction is very
comfortable felt really good in my hand
felt like i could do a lot with it
but
right there at the edge there's that
little brown spot
he had a micro crack on that edge yeah
so as soon as i hit that pot it cut
loose i loved it feel its shape and its
look but
obvious problem
all right tripp while i know any marine
could take that blade and still continue
to fight in this competition your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure after
one strike on that vase gene your blade
only has to survive one strike on these
pots
the entire marine championship for
forged in fire lies on one swing and
i've got a big old warp in my blade so
it's not over yet
nice job
gene first off you're in one piece
you picked up that bend earlier on
but you didn't pick up any more in this
test strong blade held up good job thank
you
all right tripp looks like
gene's blade held up that means that you
cannot move forward to represent the
marine corps in our next challenge
please leave the forge
super disappointed there's really no way
to tell that you have like any minor
cracks or anything like that so you just
hey you find out when you test them
that's how we found out today gene
congratulations you've won this
competition and that means that you're
going to be moving forward into our
battle of the branches final competition
to represent the marine corps at the
marine corps anvil and that's going to
give you an opportunity to win a check
for 50 000 good job brother
[Applause]
holy cow i did not see this coming it's
been a fun ride up until now but now i
got to represent the marines
so now it's it's game on and it's about
to get real those other branch service
members better look out
a u.s naval officer sword
awesome
for over 250 years the united states
naval officer sword has been a
distinguished and integral piece of
uniform for navy personnel both ornate
and functional the weapon is often
engraved and features a lightweight
straight blade that was key for melee
combat aboard crowded vessels its sleek
design was also instrumental in defense
featuring a knuckle bow guard to cover
the hand although the officer's sword
underwent several design changes and was
eventually suspended from combat
operations it is still worn in
ceremonies as a symbol of naval
authority
all right sailors your weapons looks
beautiful but it's time to find out if
they're wall hangers or they're actually
something you could use to kill
jared you're first you ready for this
i'm ready
[Music]
foreign
all right jared the balance you have
here
feels good in the hand now your edge is
very sharp as you can see with every cut
it cuts deep for every thrust all the
way through and true overall sir your
weapon will kill
thank you good job
all right lee it's your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this
that's a lot of hog to go through with a
skinny blade i'm pretty nervous
all right the
handle construction is comfortable
your edge not one
single glint or rolling your tip
punctures and cuts on the way out and
overall sir
it will kill yes
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the dreaded flex test
for the test the strength of your blade
i'll be bending it in both directions
up to that red point
jared you ready for this i guess okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm impressed
uh your blade is just as straight as
when we started the test
that's a really nice heat treat thank
you holding your sword
you can shorten that handle just a
little bit scale-wise but at the same
time it winds up being fairly
comfortable nicely done thanks
all right lee you're up you ready for
this yes sir this is the strength test
this is what is really gonna push our
blades it's a sink or swim moment
the longest five seconds of my life
but i'm holding my breath and just
praying that it holds together
nice job lane that blade is still the
same shape and started it that's
impressive thank you sir really good
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test we call this the fish
slice
we're gonna be lowering those fish down
i'm just gonna start cutting i'm gonna
keep cutting until i run out of fish all
right jared you're up first are you
ready i'm ready okay
[Music]
this is why i love sabres
they are just so much fun to cut with
it's just passing right through the fish
beautifully your handle construction
might be a little bit
wide but it's comfortable and it stays
in my hand i think you did a great job
thank you
lee you ready
yes sir okay
[Music]
all right lee cuts beautifully
i mean the edge on this
is wonderful
saber's definitely sharp and a great
balance nicely done thanks sir
jared and i are neck and neck i mean
both blades performed great
jared lee only one of you can move
forward and that smith is
[Music]
lee congratulations you'll be moving
forward to represent the united states
navy in the battle of the branch's final
competition congratulations good job
thank you jared unfortunately your blade
didn't make the cut and david baker's
going to tell you why jared you brought
us an effective cutting sword but this
came down to the basic details of
aesthetics and the way that weapon felt
in my hand i understand
well jared come on forward brother
i didn't win but i did two uh very
awesome sword
lee you did well give him hell and take
it home from the navy
lee congratulations you forged your way
into this final competition
where you'll compete against the air
force army and marine corps to bring
home the title a forged and fire
champion to the united states navy and
you'll also be competing to receive a
check for 50 000 you've done a fantastic
job you're only halfway there
and we'll see you real soon
good job thank you sir i just won
really really really
being able to represent the navy is
an honor i am totally ready to do this
all over again and i'm going to tell you
guys to bring your eight game because
i'm bringing mine
my name is tyler hackbarth i'm the army
champion to be representing the army
it's extraordinary i've got my chance to
not only be that guy to win this for the
army but there's fifty thousand dollars
at stake so i'm gonna have to give her
hell and come out on top
master sergeant gene hodges i'm
representing 200 000 marines out there
that have been going for 243 years
i like to think that i can think fast
and adapt adjust and overcome
bladesmiths congratulations you fellas
have made it into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
general george washington's lion-headed
cutto
one of only two swords worn by general
george washington during the
revolutionary war the lion-headed kutto
was washington's trusted sidearm during
early american engagements
he was proud that the weapon was made in
america having been custom forged by a
bladesmith in
philadelphia lethal in battle the sword
was designed for rapid cuts and brutal
thrusts to take down an opponent in the
famous painting washington crossing the
delaware artist emmanuel loitsa places a
more refined weapon at the general's
left side which he did not acquire until
several years later
in reality the sword carried by
washington on that fateful crossing was
likely his line-headed cutter
all right veterans welcome to the keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
weapon to deliver killing blows to this
big carcass tyler you're up first ready
[Laughter]
i'm ready
[Music]
all right tyler your handle construction
just right
your edge
is very sharp
overall sir
this saber
will kill perfect
all right gene your turn sir are you
ready let's do this doug
[Music]
all right genes this is a heavy sword
very forward heavy but when you have a
forward heavy blade that you're hitting
it meets resistance
a cylindrical
almost
circular handle
makes a twist in my hand so probably
this is the reason why the chain came
off
but your blade is sharp
it will heal
all right gentlemen december 25th 1776
george washington leads the continental
army across a frozen delaware river to
attack the hessians at trenton new
jersey and he probably didn't chip his
way through the ice but that's not going
to keep us from our strength test the
ice block chop
tyler you're up first are you ready uh
yeah yeah let's do it
all right so tyler your chain fell off
but there's no damage on your edge
your handle's comfortable other than the
chain you nailed it job
all right gene
do it
all right gene your blade's edge
is still there and it's still sharp the
issue is
uh the rest of your chain fell off and
it's picked up a bend
i have less issue with that and more
issue with this polished handle it's
just hard to hold on to
but
it's just strong
and it does have an edge so good job
yeah
all right veterans our sharpness test
today is the hessian charge
this is all about what your edge will do
to these gummies
tyler are you up first you ready for
this yep
all right tyler the weight of your
weapon does prevent me from going very
fast but you have a very sharp edge all
the way through your weapon sir it will
cut thank you
all right gene it's your turn sir are
you ready let's do this doug
all right gene to be able to maintain a
good grip on this more of the cuts i
create are more impact as opposed to a
slash where it cuts all the way through
so you have some cuts here that are more
nicks
deep nicks because you have a very sharp
edge
and for this tester your weapon
will cut awesome
it takes a lot of guts to get out there
and compete i'm glad i did it and to
come this far is pretty amazing it
definitely got the competition that i
was expecting from gene but i think it's
going to come down to the wire
between the both of us at the end of
this
tyler gene first of all i want to thank
you both for your service
you're both champions in my mind you've
already won your branch divisions but
there can only be one battle of the
branches champion
and you'll walk out of here with a check
for 50
000
and that champion is
tyler congratulations you are the battle
of the branches forged and fire champion
gene
the blade didn't make the cut
please surrender your blade
there's a lot of marines out there and
there's a lot of great guys in the
marine corps and so for me to stand here
and represent them is pretty humbling
tyler congratulations you overcame every
obstacle set in front of you you beat
out all the other smiths and now you're
the battle of the branches forged and
fired champion that's a title that comes
with a check for 50 000
and most importantly
bragging rights good job my brother
please present your blade to the judges
i'm super excited when this whole thing
started i had no idea how it was all
gonna turn out feels good to
have represented the army the fact that
i just won fifty thousand dollars is
starting to set in
i'm sergeant tyler hackmark and i'm the
new battle the branches champion
you